welcome back to New Rockstars it's me Mt
and the day that wakanda forever enters
our eyeballs draws near people as we
will all get the unique pleasure of
watching beautiful black bald women
fight Fierce and feisty fishy freaks in
just a few weeks but as we get closer to
the wakanda forever Premiere being the
impatient nerd that I am I just cannot
help but wonder what major surprises we
should expect to come out of this
biggest war in the MCU since Avengers
end game because this is easily set to
be Marvel Studios most action-packed
emotional roller coaster ever so you
know some huge jaw-dropic moments are
about to go down in this movie so let's
see if we can speculate on some of those
jaw-dropping moments together my
speculation Nation nerd babies because I
truly think that the Marvel Studios has
some really massive surprises to get the
people talking in this here movie but
you know what the people are also
talking about new rockstarsmerch.com
where you can find our newest latest
Obsession shirts and all of our amazing
nerd options over there like you should
pick up our newest latest Obsession
shirt inspired by chihulk and House of
the Dragon because those are going away
forever like I don't even know if
they're still around at this point so
pick those up immediately all right so
the first major wakanda forever surprise
that I definitely think that everyone
should expect is the return of one Tony
Stark to the Marvel Cinematic Universe
and yes while I do know that Tony
Stark's corpse started to Tony stank up
the place after the Infinity Stones
flash fried his internal organs and end
game I also know that in the world of
comic books no one ever stays completely
dead people die all the time and they
come back it's fine death is just a
minor inconvenience at the most and
since we do know that a certain iron
hero is set to make her MCU debut within
wakanda forever with actress Dominique
Thorne playing Riri Williams any true
ironheart fan knows that a surprised
Tony Stark returned from the grave is a
core part of riri's origin story in the
comics mainly when a copy of Tony
Stark's Consciousness became the
artificial intelligence for ironheart
suit after Tony Stark was brutally
killed during the events of the second
superhuman Civil War thanks Captain
Marvel you know much like Jarvis and
Friday where the AI buddies for Tony in
the movies but unlike Jarvis or Friday
because this was a full copy of Tony
Stark's mind this artificial
intelligence was basically Tony Stark in
a can and was able to Mentor ironheart
during her first days of carrying the
iron mantle I think that by the end of
wakanda forever we could see The Return
of Robert Downey Jr to the MCU through a
short tease of this artificial
intelligence arriving at riri's garage
as a gift to tag along with her in her
ironheart solo series you know much like
Tony Stark surprised Peter Parker with
his new suit at the end of Civil War and
speaking of Spider-Man we know from the
existence of Edith from far from home
that Tony Stark believed that even in
death I'm the hero so he for sure
prepared some type of way to download
his Consciousness especially since we
know that people like Zola have done
this before in the MCU Canon but another
surprise that I think we can definitely
expect for wakanda forever is the final
appearance of t'challa in the MCU and no
I'm not saying that Marvel Studios is
going to recreate Chadwick boseman's
likeness with CG technology to have him
and shuri drive off into different
directions Fast and Furious style that's
not what I'm suggesting is going to
happen that'd be weird please don't do
that Marvel however what's super special
about wakanda and the Black Panther
story in general is that in this culture
death is not the end and I have a strong
feeling that we are going to see
t'challa amongst the rest of the
wakandan kings in the ancestral plain at
some point in wakanda forever but not in
his human form because of course
Chadwick Boseman is no longer with us he
will instead be in his spiritual Panther
form while being visited by his sister
shuri because if remember in Black
Panther 1 before he has a conversation
with his father to Chaka t'challa sees
his father transformed from a panther to
a human person because we know from the
wakanda forever trailers that Queen
Ramona says the line my entire family is
gone which seems to suggest to me that
at some point during this war of
mermaids and metal we might very well
see what appears to be the death of
shuri in this movie and queen Ramona
grieving what she thinks is the loss of
her entire family to talk
however much like t'challa was saved
with the heart-shaped herb after he was
tossed off of the waterfall at depth's
door I can see shuri being saved in a
similar way here right before getting
her Panther Brothers silent ancestral
plain blessing and saying her final
emotional goodbye to t'challa much like
t'challa got to do with his father to
Chaka before ashuri emerges from The
ancestral plain as the mcu's New Black
Panther so I personally expect to see
t'challa's final canonical MCU
appearance to be in this movie this
video is brought to you by the ridge the
ridge wallet is light sleek and
Industrial and it's designed to fit in
your front pocket unlike those bulky old
old-school wallets that make you look
like you're smuggling and 80s car phone
in your back pocket it's ridiculous
check this out nice and Sleek there are
over three colors and styles including
carbon fiber and birds titanium and it
holds up to 12 cards and still has room
for cash in the back and every Ridge
wallet comes with a lifetime guarantee
and they'll let you test drive it for 45
days and send it back for a full refund
if you don't love it which you will and
the wallets have over forty thousand
five star reviews and it's made with
RFID blocking technology that protects
you from digital pickpocketers and they
also have other cool products like this
commuter backpack it's weatherproof and
great for toting around a laptop so get
15 off today with free worldwide
shipping and free returns by going to
ridge.com new rockstars that's ridge.com
new rockstars and use the code new
rockstars find the link in this video's
description and we thank Bridge again
for sponsoring this video but lastly
while I do think that we will also see
these beloved Heroes Cameo I also think
that we can expect the cameos of past
villains that we never thought that we'd
see again as well mainly the two main
villains of Black Panther 1 Ulysses claw
and Eric hillmonger because much like I
stated in my recent video on Ulysses
claw I'm willing to bat to my left arm
that Andy Circus is not done with the
MCU and will be teased as the main
villain for the New Black Panther to
fight in in the sequel to wakanda
forever because if you're familiar with
the character of claw from the comics
you'd know that he didn't really have a
normal human body for the majority of a
super villain career because he had his
body and Consciousness turned into
living Sound Vibrations that could never
truly die I have a feeling that by the
end of wakanda forever we could see The
Return of Ulysses clock to the MCU with
a completely new Sonic body after his
physical form perished at the hands of
killmonger in Black Panther 1 probably
with the help of the leader and the new
world order that he's working with and
whatever version of the Intelligentsia
that Ulysses claw was affiliated with
before Age of Ultron that is apparently
nothing like the Intelligentsia from
She-Hulk because if you think about it
claw created his prosthetic arm based on
a wakandan mining tool that helps render
vibranium inert and Shiri herself is a
heavily Sonic based hero and vibranium
sound expert with Sonic Blast hands of
her own as we saw demonstrated in Black
Panther 1. this being the case Claw is
literally the perfect Nemesis for sure
to do battle with in a black panther 3.
but anyways like I alluded to before I
also think that we can see The Return of
fan favorite Marvel villain Eric
killmonger to the MCU proper mostly
because wakanda forever is meant to be a
celebration of t'challa's unique impact
on wakanda and the world in general and
the direct source of that massive impact
came directly from t'challa having the
most Compassionate Heart The wakandan
Throne has ever seen like think about it
guys think back to Civil War when
t'challa had his father's dead body in
his arms after Zemo killed him and the
rage that t'challa had in his eyes as he
chased who he thought was his father's
killer that same beautiful Panther man
when he found out that zema was
responsible for his father's death saved
the life of his father's killer instead
of giving in to his anger like Steve and
Tony were in the room next door because
that is the kind of man t'challa was a
good man with a good heart and hell
t'challa even yelled at that same dead
father that he missed so much in front
of his father's fathers when he realized
just how badly his dad treated his
cousin killmonger when killmonger was a
kid that very same cousin that just
threw him off of a waterfall but Chalo
was a selfless man who cared so much
about the sanctity of life so this all
being said I do not believe for a second
that chachala that his cousin killmonger
die after he stabbed him at the end of
black panther because if vibranium power
technology could have saved Everett
Ross's life after he got hurt in the
first Black Panther movie that a man
literally covered in vibranium nanites
at the moment of a stabbing could
survive a stab moon with the power of
compassion and a little bit of wakandan
science so I definitely would expect to
see The Return of one Aaron killmonger
very soon but those are the major
surprises that I believe we might see in
wakanda forever but what do you guys
think let us know if you guys have any
future surprise predictions of your own
in the comment section below but thank
you guys so much for watching this video
and you can follow me at mastertonment
on Twitter if you want to see me tweet
some weird [ __ ] but most importantly you
could follow new rockstars or wherever
we are on the social media and of course
do not forget to hit up the
rockstarsmerch.com today to pick up our
newest latest Obsession shirts and all
of our amazing nerd options over there
but again thank you guys so much for
watching this video love you guys so
much and I'll see you guys next time
goodbye
[Music]